aber ich meine das alles will ich wenn
ich den bisschen hoch nehmen wir die
beiden sind auf jeden fall luca wenn du
das nicht mal hohe game hoch liegt aber
so war das licht in einem zimmer ok
freunde ich meine da machen wir doch
erst mal hier hinten das licht aus dann
hier vorne noch eben die softbox aus und
jetzt noch die proben eben die stocks
wie wollt ihr euch jetzt aussehen
verdacht geschöpft
ich mache jetzt einfach mal nur hinten
die beleuchtung aus ich hoffe das passt
euch weil wenn ich hier die beleuchtung
aus mache dann seht ihr mich einfach
nicht mehr es ist gerade 22 uhr die
sonne ist untergegangen herzlich
willkommen zu 5 live set freddy sway es
gibt niemanden der hier gerade weniger
bock drauf hat als ich habe das ganze
game schon mal auf meinem kanal
hochgeladen
deswegen steht hier fordern noch
continue or at night gewonnen aber ich
würde sagen wir kriegen einfach mal auf
bevor ich auf ein jugendlicher erklärt
euch erst mal ganz kurz 259 freddys geht
es darum dass wir in einer pizzeria
arbeiten
das ist quasi alles nur in dieser
pizzeria leben auch gefährliche monster
und die wollen uns töten und wir fangen
an musste nur kurz im handbuch holen
falls ich wieder spitze warum klingt
jetzt das verfügte telefon der typ
erklärt uns jetzt von wegen ja ich habe
danach richte dich hier du passt es hier
auf und wir haben halt nur eine gewisse
anzahl der energie also ich seh schon
unten links powernap 96 wieso ich hab
gerade angefangen ich denke oben einfach
mal eben auf dem youtube macht auch
erstmal hier das licht kann ich
eigentlich auch mal aus mal an ich habe
sogar gar nichts an wieso geht meine
pause schnell runter das ganze spiel für
alle die neu und funktioniert so dass
ich unten ein bildschirm habe und ihr
seht schon dort ist eine person dort ist
eine person und hier vorne ist auch noch
so eine komische person und ich befinde
mich hier unten und die befinden sich
hier oben und die müssen durch diese
ganzen räume durch um zu mir zu gelangen
sie können sich allerdings nur bewegen
wenn ich den bildschirm wegstecke das
heißt es könnte sein das ist jetzt schon
jemand hier ist oder das jetzt kann ich
mach das licht mal lieber wieder aus ihr
seht schon unten links wären nur noch 88
prozent ist es immer noch nur zwölf ruhe
jetzt ist es eine [ __ ] und irgendwann
wird es in diesem video hier der fall
sein dass nicht unten ihre den laptop
aufklappen und ihr seht schon dass eine
personen von denen ist dann halt einfach
wegwaschen ganze stadt dabei würden
wieder
ich bin krank ich habe viele manchmal
den ganzen rudi bachelorarbeit schreiben
und ich bin nicht durchschaut ausspielen
aber gut freunde bevor ich jetzt jemand
das licht anmachen oder so guck ich erst
mal ganz kurz durch den bildschirm sehen
doch alle drei leute sind noch da das
ist nämlich eigentlich zu beginn
wirklich immer so der fall also es
dauerte bis 23 uhr in der ersten nacht
muss sie sich bewegen ich kann übrigens
nicht nur cam 1a anschauen wo die sich
derzeit befinden sollen auch kämen fünf
oder camsex die ist gerade zum beispiel
ausgefallen das ist nämlich auch so eine
beschissene sache und zwar kann es
einfach zwischendurch sein dass die dass
die leute sich irgend welchen räumen
verstecken wo die kamera alt war die
funktioniert
als kunde das heutige ziel ist auf jeden
fall dass ich die erste nacht überleben
das habe ich gesagt wenn ich das schaffe
bin ich zufrieden ja wir können wir
links gucken da ist ja nichts los
manchmal eben das nicht wieder aus sagen
wir mal rechts gucken eben das auch
nichts ich guck mal kurz auf meine
aufnahmen überhaupt überall läuft ich
das ganze hier normal spielen muss jetzt
wird schon mal wieder auf dem bildschirm
ich wusste das ist schon zu früh sein
wird dass eine abbauen also wo ist mein
spiel halo man denkt sich jetzt
vielleicht als zuschauer an
das ist doch die sie wie sie hier das
ist ein spiel das geschieht nur auf
bildern je alter guckt euch mal andere
pfeifen da ist der freddy - an der
kopten gar nicht mehr klar es kann sein
dass die person schon hier links die das
kann aus einer solchen hier rechts steht
ist nicht der fall wir sind 216 m
überleben also noch vier stunden
es ist schon einer zeit freunde es wird
schon mal wieder auf dem bildschirm und
wir sehen schon er ist immer noch ein
kleines bier da bin ich auf jeden fall
froh darüber haben wir auch noch beide
am start man hat das ganze spiel
übrigens geschafft wenn man ja der titel
sagt schon wenn man fünf nächte überlebt
hat wir haben noch 65 prozent akku übrig
haben jetzt auch nur noch drei stunden
das heißt es geht eigentlich gerade ganz
gut aus weil ich mich halt noch nicht so
sehr hiermit beschäftige aber okay ich
mache das alles ziemlich wenn ich den
mädchen hochnehmen sehen wie die beiden
sind auf jeden fall noch erste usa
stehen mal aufkam 7 da ist ein licht
kämen 15 auch mich freunde kämen drei
m30 ausgefallen ich gehe auf camp 2 da
ist es auf der pinken camp zwei jahre da
ist es einfach das fenster des wahnsinns
ich meine wenn ich jetzt mal auf täglich
gesehen wie die beiden zumindest noch
daher steht immer noch bei cam zwei
jahre das heißt er steht jetzt quasi bei
mir hier links hinten an den gang steht
er gerade das heißt wir nicht aus den
augen verlieren ham 1a immer noch beide
vornamen start
du bist übels korrekt du bist mega
korrekt und er steht einfach in diesem
verdammten gang was soll das bruder hey
willst du mich verarschen ich will ich
bin nicht so viel verbrauchen deswegen
möchte ich am liebsten immer
zwischendurch so ein bisschen
und weil ich dann machen und ein
bisschen stellen und so aber man scheiße
vielleicht überlege ich nicht mal die
erste nacht aber bisher muss ich
wirklich sagen wir haben zwölf überlebt
1 uhr und 2 und wir müssen es nur noch 3
uhr den rest schaffen hier und fünf sind
noch komplett ist und also schon mal
wieder hier rein wir sehen es steht
immer noch am ende des gangs diese auch
bei samstag ist ein blöder alter hier
sind meine hobbys manier steht dahinter
der andere wird jeden moment zu mir
kommen und mir in james kerr verpassen
samstag zum beispiel nein nein nein nein
nein
[Musik]
also noch mal kurz zur erklärung dams
games sind an dem man denkt die ganze
zeit alles ist cool dann auf einmal und
man erschreckt sich des todes teil i
love you guys that schild der einfach
und er gilt halt hier also ein schild
halt auch aber erschüttert
legt euch weg durch nein ich bin einfach
nur wieder auf steam gibt ja ich mache
diese horror games serie also ihr könnt
jetzt leichter lassen und wenn ihr
90.000 leichter da kommt nächste woche
wieder ein horror game und das könnt ihr
mir und in die kommentare schreiben
das voll vergessen zu sagen hier weil
ich die ganze zeit auf dieses spiel
gegen die fokussiert bin also der typ
ist auf jeden fall immer noch in diesem
gang er kann sich auch wirklich nur
bewegen wenn wir jetzt die cams wünschen
deswegen bleibe ich die ganze zeit ist
schon hier die sache ist halt auch das
ist gerade fünf uhr nachts ist die
anderen beiden brüder sind natürlich
noch da hinten das heißt ich es wünsche
natürlich schnell wieder zurück m2a und
ich würde sagen ich habe einfach noch 24
prozent übrig wir beenden die ersten
acht jetzt einfach dadurch dass ich die
ganze zeit hier bleibe es wäre jetzt
natürlich hart scheiß wintercamp
bruder tun mir das nicht ich habe noch
nicht erzählt was passiert wenn der akku
leer
wie kann das sein
wie kann das sein wie kann das sein
haye macht deutlich hier machen wir
natürlich noch eine nacht meine freunde
natürlich nicht nur eine zweite nacht
jetzt weil die erste mit natürlich nicht
überstanden aber wir bestimmen wir
finden uns wieder in nacht 150 mal hoch
und sehen alle drei sind auch da das auf
jeden fall eine schöne schöne nachricht
auf jeden fall verließ finde ich viel
viel schlimmer als ländern natürlich
gibt es die atlas oder irgendwie so alle
drei sind auf jeden fall noch hinter dem
rauen das erst mal schön und gut
natürlich gibt es noch atlas oder vor
allem ich war vorhin um 5 uhr sa/so
getötet das war voll im schaffen der
zweiten nacht auf den punkt zurück zu
kommen natürlich gibt es doch games wie
aus glas oder so ich meine körner horror
spiel wieder offen in die kommentare
schreiben aber eher dass die in dem ich
glaube die mbi noch nicht so ganz
gewachsen da sehen wir uns dann
vielleicht einen 17 wochen mal eugene
ist quasi so der verbrauch die mir
gerade haben also der
relativ human weil wir ja gerade quasi
nur in unserer kammer hier schön aber
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise die noch
aufmache sehen wir schon 23 meine
zuschauer sind ja auch hauptsächlich
irgendwie wirklich so ja keine ahnung 12
bis 18 oder so das spiel ist einfach ab
eigentlich müssen wir abschalten
hat dir dieser musik
sind nicht dumm oder irgendeine musik
ich weiß nicht ob die musik jetzt dafür
stand dass einer da hinten abgabe
wahrscheinlich ja wahrscheinlich nie hat
der übelste bastard von den dreien da
bist du wieder an 1b erstmal leser nicht
ist ein fixer man ey incam 1a sind nur
noch die beiden brüder am start der
andere steht hier vorne ewig geburt man
warum es gar nicht so dumm gucken jetzt
also er steht auf jeden fall bei kämpfen
gerade und die anderen sind 1a das heißt
wir unser
du [ __ ]
nein das ist johanna wir haben nur noch
ihnen nur ersten bruder sei er steht
hier vorne kam 5th snec wo ist der aus
campingfreunde bodes der hauptfilm
verdammte scheiße in einem raum ist der
typ aus camp 5 und vorhin in deiser nein
das war keine mainzer also erst auf
jeden fall bruder camp 5 des beckham
einst ps einer kenntlich gemacht
das kann doch nicht wahr sein hey ich
mache mir die zeit schlechter horror
game spieler ich habe zweimal nicht die
erste nacht von 519 freudiges geschaut
ich schwöre euch freunde ich gebe alles
in dieser scheiß horrorserie aber ich
krieg ist einfach nicht interessiert so
freunde ich weiß nicht ob man sieht aber
mir läuft hier überall der schweiß
runter sieht man hier nie das sieht man
sogar doch hier vorne sieht man so ein
bisschen mein schweizer messer
ich bin gerade so hart am verrecken man
könnte auch denkt ich bin grad einen
marathon oder irgendwie sowas gelaufen
er freunde meine stimme schon voll am
arsch gerade wenn ihr wollt dass die
nächste woche wieder ein horror game
spiele dann last light da und dann mache
ich das aber glaubt nicht dass wir das
spaß macht hier sonst findet ihr jetzt
hier oben ein smiley eingeblendet wenn
er da draufsteht könnte meinen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren da oben finde ich
auch meinen shop eingeblendet und hier
unten ist keine ahnung was der verlinke
erhalten ja ich bin total